the restrict Act is supposed to ban
Tick-Tock but it actually does much more
than that and Tick Tock in the great you
know tradition of laws that are
obviously tailored to one thing but you
know but have much broader application
it doesn't actually mention Tick Tock
what does the restrict act do and what
should we be worried about yeah so it's
a extremely broad law and you know there
could be a good reason to not mention
Tick Tock to be just transparently clear
a law that specifically calls out a
corporation and finds them guilty of a
crime or a person for that matter would
be a bill of attainder unconstitutional
under our American system for other
reasons which that was Senator hawley's
Bill by the way uh and Rand Paul
specifically called him out for that
because Holly's bill was targeting
Tick-Tock and it's illegal exactly so we
don't have that infirmity with the
restrict act but we have a different one
and in many ways a more dangerous one
because rather than zeroing in on a
specific Corporation or company Tick
Tock this bill is giving basically
unrestricted powers to the Secretary of
Commerce to identify information
Technologies and transactions or
Holdings Financial Holdings related to
those information Technologies and
simply say that Americans are not
allowed to make those transactions or
have those Holdings and there's very
little process for how they make those
determinations other than the fact that
the information technology is
advantageous to a foreign adversary I
guess in this case we're assuming it's
China but it could be anyone and there's
no limitations or there's very few
limitations
with regard to who can challenge or
rather there are limitations as to who
can challenge designations once they're
made by the Secretary of Commerce and we
can get more into that it's particularly
relevant to us at coin Center where
we're focused on cryptocurrency
Technologies because we're actually
fighting some of these sorts of battles
with respect to an existing statute for
sanctioning or blocking transactions the
international economic emergency Powers
Act and the ofac regime that comes from
that act of Congress so you know one
thing we've done is we look at the
restrict Act is compare and contrast
does this create new powers are we going
to be fighting treasuries ofac
designations as well as the Secretary of
commerce's restrict act designations and
would it be more or less difficult to
challenge Secretary of commerce's
designations under restrict then it has
been thus far for us to challenge ofac
designations when they go beyond the
actual statutory Authority yeah let's
and let's get to that because the
restrict Act is really kind of applying
an existing law against various kinds of
you know that affect crypto and other
things to Media but I just want to say
you know to me part of what is strikes
me as insane about this it's a twofold
process first you have Congress actually
see getting so much power to the
executive branch you know this is a
long-running problem I think within a
reason style libertarian analysis of
government sometime over the past 50
years and maybe maybe since Andrew
Jackson Congress has just stopped
actually doing what it's supposed to be
doing and it's just offloading you know
it's it's it's Outsourcing what it's
supposed to be doing to Congress
which is nuts to begin with and then so
there's that problem and then it's like
the Secretary of Commerce there are
probably 80 percent of the people in
Congress could not name who the Commerce
Secretary is and you give them massive
broad Powers I mean the Commerce
Secretary is to the you know to Cabinet
offices what Cornell is to the ivy
league you know it's it's a it's a
secondary tertiary seller dweller kind
of cabinet level so it just seems nuts
that you know this this is what's in
front of us
some members of Congress who aren't even
aware that their own name is a
co-sponsor to the bill yeah no I mean
but this this gets to this right where
it's like
um you know Congress no longer I mean
they've you know they don't declare Wars
they don't do anything
um and like how do you how do you battle
that when you're you know when you're
talking about the restrict act and
earlier you know existing laws
um that end up giving massive amounts of
power to the administrative State
essentially
um you know how do you how do you start
clawing back uh you know agency it's
really hard because as you said this has
been going on for a long time maybe
since Andrew Jackson certainly since the
um since the New Deal and and
Roosevelt's expansion of of the
executive powers therein and you know
there's this public facing rationale for
that that a lot of people have bought or
or sort of bought into for a long time
now it goes all the way back to Max
Weber the sociologist who said that as
the subject of law the things that law
needs to regulate become more complex
and technological and he was probably
thinking about I don't know steam
engines and things like that but God
knows it's gotten more complex that it
will be inevitable that sort of
citizen-run legislatures will have to
give up their authority to a more
technocratic bureaucratic class and so a
lot of people I think that argument if
they're not if they're just sort of
casually observers of the political
process makes sense but there's
something extremely Insidious in that
argument it's that we need to give up on
elected representatives being capable of
educating themselves sufficiently to
actually control the things that matter
most in society like our information
Technologies and our engineering
Technologies and what you end up with
then is where we are today where that
atrophy has got gotten so profound that
Congress really just sort of writes
blank checks all the time they say oh
tick tock's a problem here's a blank
check to the Secretary of Commerce to
make sure that they can ban anything
that they need to in their wisdom and
their technical expertise about the
internet that might be a threat to
American interests and that is just an
abdication of congress's Duty under the
Constitution which vests the sole
legislative power in congress not in the
executive the bright spot here and I
don't need to tell you Nick or you Zach
what this is is that our courts have
actually wised up to this and some of
our justices like Neil Gorsuch
especially are very keen to return that
separation of powers with with you know
important cases dealing with major
Powers Doctrine and the non-delegation
doctrine of the Constitution so that's
how you challenge us you challenge it in
court now hopefully we don't have to
bring a non-delegation challenge to the
restrict act because hopefully it never
passes into law but that's all a lot of
hopefuls right yeah let's look I want to
look at some of of the text here just to
underline or highlight exactly how big
of a blank check this is to the
Executive Branch the Commerce Secretary
in particular the law says the secretary
is authorized to and shall take action
to identify deter disrupt prevent
prohibit investigate or otherwise
mitigate
all of these threats that the secretary
determines poses an undo or unacceptable
risk of sabotage or subversion
that can include catastrophic effects on
the security or resilience of the
critical infrastructure or digital
economy of the United States which we
should talk about in a second here and
otherwise poses an undoer unacceptable
risks to the National Security of the
United States and then this one is the
one that blew my mind if the secretary
in his Sole and unreviewable discretion
determines that such a referral would be
in the interest of national security so
they're not missing any words as to you
know the kind of sole unreviewable
authority of this one executive
appointed official to affected a broad
swath undefinable uh swath of the
economy yeah um yeah my favorite in in
that is otherwise mitigate
so Congress is supposed to tell the
agencies in the executive branch you
know what the problem is and ideally
with some specificity like regulation of
the airwaves I.E we can't have
interference between different parts of
the Broadband spectrum and then ideally
supposed to direct them to how they're
supposed to you know carefully wield
their powers to enforce congress's will
otherwise mitigate is a completely
unbridled phrase I mean if you bomb a
data center you might otherwise mitigate
certain nasty effects coming out of that
data center surely that is not within
the intended powers that Congress seems
to be giving here but if you just look
at the plain language of the word
otherwise mitigate includes all kinds of
things that would be patently a
violation of Human Rights or Liberty or
the rule of law hey thanks for watching
that excerpt from our live conversation
with Peter Van valkenberg of coin Center
about the restrict act and its threats
not only to social media but to digital
privacy you can watch another clip from
that conversation here or the full
conversation he here